pierre morin journaliste et spécialiste
de la russie bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec moi alors qu'on l'a vu la
popularité de vladimir poutine demeure
élevé très élevé en russie
alors quels sont les facteurs qui
peuvent expliquer eh bien je crois que
le principal facteur c'est que
actuellement il n'y a pas réellement
d'alternative à vladimir poutine poutine
est un homme qui a mené la russie depuis
maintenant vingt ans il y à des progrès
qui sont effectifs à tous les niveaux et
lille a redonné à la russie d'un statut
de grande puissance
la population a bénéficié d'une
augmentation du niveau de vie qui a été
assez importante au cours de ces vingt
dernières années même si dernièrement à
la suite des différentes crises
les résultats sont moins appréciable
mais ils sont tout de même là elle est
là s'il s'agit simplement d'une phase de
consolidation d'un pouvoir qui de toute
manière même s'il peut théoriquement se
représenter pour les seize prochaines
années en fait il n'ya pas réellement de
doute que à un moment il va se retirer
il est en train simplement de préparer
la russie à sa succession n'est rien de
ses conséquences de ces votes c'est
qu'il pourra se représenter à partir de
oui il pourra se représenter cercle il
pourra qu'est-ce qu'il va le faire ça
c'est une autre histoire
en tout cas selon grève à se retirer de
la politique à terme forcément comme
disait le général de gaulle et finira
bien par se retirer ou par mourir à ça
c'est clair on meurt tous un jour où on
se retire tous un jour non je crois que
ce qui est important dans ce coup de
dents dans ce référendum constitutionnel
ce n'est pas tant qu' il puisse
représenter deux fois ce qui est
important c'est que il a modifié
sensiblement
la manière de gérer la russie jusqu'à
présent la russie était gouverné comme
la france c'est à dire un président qui
gouverne qui établit les priorités avec
un premier ministre qui exécute à partir
de maintenant en russie
c'est plus du tout pareil il y aura un
président qui s'occupe du régalien de la
sécurité de la défense des affaires
étrangères et il y aura un premier
ministre choisi par la douma c'est à
dire par la chambre basse de l'assemblée
fédérale et qui est responsable devant
elle c'est à dire qu'en fait on
introduit pour le secteur qui est le
secteur disons sociétal la société
l'économie
un pouvoir qui est différent de celui du
président le président pourra toujours
donné des indications des impulsions
mais la douma et le premier ministre
choisi par elle pourra faire ce qu'il
veut
évidemment c'est un changement à long
terme sur les lignes médian ne verra pas
la différence parce que le poids de
vladimir poutine est trop important pour
que un premier ministre quelconque
puisse prendre des libertés réelles mais
à terme ça va changer considérablement
le visage de la russie il y aura un
double réellement ce ne sera plus un
pouvoir bicéphale théorique avec un
président qui domine tout ce sera un
pouvoir bicéphale réel avec un président
qui s'occupe de la grandeur de la force
de la russie du régalien et un premier
ministre qui s'occupe de l'économie de
la société et avec cela en plus pour le
président un pouvoir de centraliser les
politiques régionales par
l'intermédiaire d'un organisme qui est
entré dans la constitution mais qui
existait déjà
qui est le conseil d'état pierre laurin
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
d'avoir été en direct sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
écrivain et spécialiste de la russie
merci